[Music]
good afternoon it's a pleasure to be
here I want to thank Wolfgang for
inviting me to this forum I've learned a
lot listening to all of you last few
days and so what I want to talk about
today is so I'm basically a neuromorphic
engineer so what does that mean I'll
tell you about it a little bit
I am the CTO of this new company called
Ada compute so ADA as you know is a is a
Greek letter for efficiencies as an
engineer efficient compute is what we're
trying to do so ADA compute that's the
origin of the words and what we're
trying to do is address a problem that
is I think potentially has some benefits
if when you try to learn from the
neuroscience literature and try to apply
or transfer knowledge if you will into
something that's going to be really
impractical so I'll tell you about the
problem but before that let's look at
this this basic idea is that there are
devices that we all use cell phones
smartwatches and so on that are just
exploding in terms of the number of
these devices everybody has people have
more than one cell phone etc etc so
these are edge devices because they
directly interact and communicate with
other machines objects and so on it's
estimated there's going to be about 50
billion of these guys by 2020 so then we
talk about 50 billion I'm talking about
agriculture radiation mining you know
you just expand the scope of all the
devices that are there it's huge it's a
potentially huge you know set of devices
so the question is you know if these
devices are involved in the so called
let's say sense in for act loop which is
because they directly interact with the
environment that if they can sense infer
an act that's the fastest loop you can
get in terms of the device in the
productivity or the efficiency of the
device but typically what we have today
is this cloud model where you have a
cloud computer computing system that
actually does the null
extraction from the data that sent up
and then it's percolates down into the
device and then it's an incarnation of
the particular you know implementation
and then it runs and then there's some
changes you've got to go back to the
cloud so cloud is more powerful but then
it's slow so the question is you know
what can we do about this agility
requirement at the edge in order to
enable all these devices to be in code
intelligent right well I mean if you
look at so what we're trying to do as a
company is look at addressing several
issues that as you know as a company we
talked a lot of car you know vendors and
and people who are interested in solving
problems and for them these are all some
of the grounded list of things that they
worry about so you have data volume
meaning that you know a car we'll be
talking about autonomous cars today four
terabytes an hour roughly is what the
number is and if you all the cars in the
world have these you can imagine the
data volume that you're generating there
how do you deal with that what can you
do about it do you have to go to the
cloud every single instance of the data
that is sampled or is there any way to
deal with all this what what's going on
there what can we do there energy of
course I mean you have a cell phone you
have limited battery you know you have
very little energy and so what can you
do there privacy is an important
requirement seems like so people for
example there's a you know this thing
about somebody looking at your
monitoring you all the time when you
talk to your Amazon echo or the devices
like that security people there's an
actually a demonstration that happened
recently in California where people were
able to remotely log into a car's
computer and apply the brakes or you
know control the car basically remotely
so they could break in basically and so
you know if you think of a car as an
edge device then that's an issue
security and then these other things for
example latency virtual reality is an
issue where if you have a visual latency
in the signals that are coming in you're
going to have a big problem you're going
to have you know your head start going
spin because of the the latency problem
so these are all issues and so people
are interested in addressing this at the
so what are we doing about it I'll talk
in a first I'll go into a little bit of
neuroscience you've got you're all
expert but I just want to sort of
compiled a list of thoughts and then in
the end I'll show you a demonstration of
the chip that we have today that does
you know the basic sort of shows you the
basic principles of how it works so the
first point I want to make is about
neuromorphic systems and computing in
general so this is originally coined by
knew you know originally it was just
called neuromorphic electronics to
basically describe analog circuits that
mimic neurobiological architectures and
circuits in the nervous system so
basically this was way back in the 80s
mid 80s Carver Mead had a huge NSF
Center out of which came a whole Legion
of neuromorphic you know professors if
you will they're all over the world now
but today neuromorphic engineering /
computing is what it's known for is
basically they've expanded the scope
from just being analog circuits to being
everything in the in the world of
electronics including software systems
so digital mix more analog VLSI and
software systems so that's what I mean
by when I say neuromorphic computing and
so now I'm going to get into this idea
of the idea that you know brain evolved
over millions of years and the
constraints that it actually evolved
based on was actually very simple and it
seems like it's a very simple idea of
benefit and cost so what I mean by that
is you have this selective pressure that
says well we have to generate adaptive
behavior where information processing
under changing conditions right so
that's the benefit but then that come to
the cost you have to minimize the energy
consumed during the process so it's sort
of like a yin and yang of the of the
equation here that energy and
information seems to be sort of butting
against each other and if you can solve
this problem of a source or figure out
how evolution has solved this problem at
various scales and the brain that we see
today has
seems to reflect some of those choices
that were made over millions of years
maybe suggestive of how we could design
neuromorphic systems that could be
interesting so so if you look at so I'm
going to start talk about a compilation
of work that has been done by others but
sort of may try to make my point about
this link between energy and information
first so the nervous system as you all
know very well consumes 20% of the
energy for just 2% of the body mass but
then bulk of this energy is for action
potential generation it's maintenance
and the signal transmission through the
synapse so if you look at it from an
engineering point of view you know
talking about bandwidth noise and
propagation are the other three features
that we care about in this particular
process here and bandwidth means
signaling speed noise a signal quality
and you know propagation is basically
signal transmission so if you think
about the of the more than which these
neurons communicate it seems like you
know this classic information theory
thing where if this seems like action
potentials are the way and so if it's if
a neuron doesn't spike at all there is
no information if it spikes all the time
there is no information so this is happy
medium somewhere in between various
there is information and information
here is in the sense of Shannon so you
know the quantities that we care about
here was actually measured for the for
the spike timing is actually in a
measured by a beautiful experiment in
Princeton by strong at all in 1998 so
they measured the the I wouldn't be able
to say this properly I'm not a
neuroscientist but in the more in the
motion area they stimulated a neuron or
a set of neurons with a signal like you
see on the top there top left and then
the measured are recorded the activity
of some neurons in that area as a
function of time and they wanted to
measure both the signal entropy and the
noise entropy from the data and so for
those who don't know there's a signal
entropy means you you sort of sent a
long stimuli and measure the entropy of
that signal by measuring the by looking
at windows of time the width of the
window has various which of the windows
and
for edge of S which is entropy for
information and then similarly you do
that for noise meaning that you present
the sister the signal over and over
again and you measure the variance or
the noise and then you subtract the two
you get information and the ratio of the
information to the you know Spike
entropy would be the efficiency so what
they found is basically that here the
plot says information rate on the y-axis
and entropy rate on the x-axis for
smaller and smaller windows the
information rate produced was what was
much better so the tighter the window
the more you know information rates were
achieved you can sort of think of it
more along the lines of that curve
they're mentioned that doesn't
necessarily mean just one millisecond
but it would be a small window within
which the spikes that are that appear
are much more information than they're
not and then if you look at neural
morphology if you look at the the size
and and distribution of the axonal
tracts and the neurons themselves it
seems to suggest that evolution has also
tried to balance these two information
rate versus efficiency so in this plot
here it seems to suggest that you know
the smaller the neurons the lower the
information rate but then it's much
better in terms of efficiency so the
complexity in the neuron is got to be
traded off with the efficiency and so
there's a distribution of these of these
neurons foreland in biology that allows
you to make that trade-off and then not
only that you have the distribution of
the axonal tracts that are skewed more
towards thin axons so most of the axons
that you find are skewed towards thin
axons and furthermore phenox axons have
lower firing rates than thicker ones so
so suggesting that you know there's a
bias there again or sort of a trade-off
that was sort of evolved over time to
have this set of a distribution and then
if you look at the at a larger scale
you know the cortex level or the whole
brain there seems with this balance
between dense short and sparse long
range connectivity to to enable
efficient behavior so dense short range
would
would basically extract information from
the environment but then you know they
but then in order to generate the system
level behavior you need to integrate all
this information so there are thicker
longer axons spread among these thinner
lower information rate axons
that integrate all the information and
then also solve this problem synaptic
Pat length where a neuron in one one
area to bring prefrontal say to the
occipital lobe can be rapid so that the
information exchange is also pretty good
so a bunch of problems there that are
solved by balancing these two then if
you look at the neurons itself in more
detail the channel properties the
voltage-gated channels the you know for
example control the threshold threshold
obviously means the the lower the
threshold the higher the spike rate
which means higher information rate and
so there's more energy consumed and so
on so all these different evolutionary
features that that showed up sort of
balances these two at the lowest of
lower you know denomination so if you
want to call it the cellular level
similarly the the neurons are never
allowed to spike I mean there's a
regulation of its own firing rate self
regulation of its own firing rate in
order to keep the information rate in a
more balanced state and also there seems
to be a new data suggesting that the
myelination of the axonal tracts also
controls you know basically the
information rate that is transferred per
Joule this is work by fields in 2015 so
going on if you look at the biophysics
now of the transmission of the the
synaptic action potential through the
synapse into the postsynaptic side if
you define two terms like probability of
the vesicle release on to the
postsynaptic cell SP and the probability
of the presynaptic spark occurrences s
then you can sort of see a beautiful
work by Harris at i'll shows how these
two are related in controlling
information rates so for example the top
blood on this shows that the fraction of
information transmitted is linearly
varies with s which may meaning that if
the presynaptic neuron doesn't spike a
lot
meaning s is very small
then you know the release a bit more
release probability that it grows
linearly but then it's sub-linear or
depressive in a way 4 4 4 SS that are
much bigger on average and then but then
if you look at the information to energy
ratio it seems like you know across
release probabilities for a higher for a
smaller s it's much better comparatively
speaking so which means that you know
it's biased towards spiking less or
picking or wanting to be in a regime
where it doesn't spike too much so that
the pre-synaptic probability of release
that the s probability is much smaller
and so it's going to be sort of
preferential to that so to keep this
balanced and then if you look at the
circuits at themselves in the cortical
circuits themselves we all know it's
it's a bunch of excitatory inhibitory
neurons tightly coupled if you zoom it
any one of them it's sort of this sort
of a ratio of 8020 roughly excited
inhibitory neurons connected all which
ways and subtle changes in the gains of
the synapses could really alter the
dynamics of the circuits but the key
thing is it seems like there is an
option here again in terms of keeping
the the activity balanced so this is
balanced current regime this beautiful
database and group that talks about how
information per spike is much more much
more higher for balanced current regimes
as opposed to the other two ways just
have excitation or just balanced
conductance and the same same deal with
the efficiency so it seems like these
systems are again calibrated to sort of
balance to promote efficiency at the
level of circuits then going into the
synapse in terms of plasticity it seems
like there's an optimal filtering of
information happening there for
efficient transfer of information so we
all know some data from Markram and
others that I've started showed how the
spikes can sort of further the ordering
of the spikes can change the the gain of
the synapse there's short-term
plasticity that regulates information
rates by lowering energy
and also of course there is you know
this this growth of spines on the on
these dendrites and to effect
information transfer and various which
ways and last but not least
neuromodulation which allows you to sort
of optimally filter at a different time
scale than probably at the synapse in
terms of spike timing-dependent
plasticity this is a citation of
Sophie's works really I've been trying
to leverage which is basically at the
population level seems like the same
principles apply where you have to
balance between excitation and
inhibition and populations of neurons to
enable information efficient information
coding and then this idea that David Cox
talked about this predictive coding
where the lower levels encode
information redundant information so
that the higher levels have energy
savings because spikes don't transmit
much upper in the higher levels if the
lower levels are good at predicting
what's going on so these kinds of you
know designs or things that appear in
biology holds relevance for you know how
you may want to architect a neuromorphic
system and the last but one of the big
things that I find is this idea of a
synchrony so you know we all know that
brain is asynchronous what I mean by
that is many clocks are rhythms not just
one particular you know mode of it and
this just-in-time mode of operation it
seems to have a have a big deal for in
terms of sufficiency I'll talk about
that from a hardware side of why that is
you know complex operations for example
you can take more more time than average
but simpler ones can just take less time
and the brain doesn't have to consume
energy doing just waiting for the other
complex one to be done and actions can
start as soon as possible depending on
what ends up happening in terms of the
the complexity so if you think about a
summary of these kinds of ideas you put
them together you know there are from
the information code coding point of
view there's control of biophysics and
there's n coding strategies if you just
look at these two what you want is you
want to make the cig
in a neuromorphic system energetically
cheap whatever means to do that if
possible should be done and there are
many ideas out there there's not just
one design there are many different
architectures and ideas out there that
that have been pursued but seems like
this event-driven or asynchronous mode
of you know sending the signals out
makes a lot of sense from the hardware
point of view and and and in AD if you
can actually mix that with low voltage
circuits as well as analog circuits in
in in computing or extracting
information and passing it on it seems
like a good idea at least so from the
encoding side what we're talking about
is circuits that require fewer signals
to carry information so not just you
know to generate the signal cheaply but
also to the number of these signals that
need to be transmitted in order to send
useful information is that the other
side so there it's about the design of
the system itself how you architect them
how are these modules connected together
is the it's a connectivity programmable
you know what kinds of densities can we
can we realize with technologies that
are there today that allows us to allows
us to to satisfy some of the
requirements here is some of the things
that we look at and study so so what I
want to shift here to is basically the
things that we're doing at ADA compute
to to address some of these things so
the first thing be realized I mean based
on what I've been doing this for more
than a decade now designed I was lead
for a project at Hughes research labs a
DARPA program called synapse where we
actually built a scenario a small chip
that actually can learn on the chip
demonstrating using spike
timing-dependent plasticity and other
features there but what seems to be the
most important for hardware at least we
want to realize or draw inspiration from
biology is this idea of a synchrony and
being able to do that in a delay
insensitive way if you can have a
hardware design that's delay insensitive
meaning that these modules
basically communicating without a clock
and the handshake they have to handshake
and you know if there is no delay in
that process if you can minimize that
delay and design hardware that does that
then there's a whole laundry list of
advantages that we can sort of leverage
so so for example low power consumption
comes in because you feel you are doing
fine-grained clock gating and there's no
this basically at standby situations
there's no power consumed really you
can't sort of control the operating
speed we have some interesting features
I'll talk about there that determine you
know the determine local latency is not
really controlled by this global clock
which is a actually a big issue with
synchronous systems most of our systems
are synchronous and the computers we
have today are synchronous it's robust
to variations in supply voltage
temperature and fabrication for those
who actually build chips these are big
these are big things I mean you really
cannot you know design circuits that are
that are sensitive to these because they
were not scalable really so analog
systems in general if you just build
pure analog which is what Carver Mead
originally was proposing was going to be
a big problem because of this reason and
then formally verifiable that is you
want to leverage the tools that are
there today to build these chips
rather than have your own custom tools
and then have that be integrated with
the current tools and it's a big
headache and so trying to build a chip
with with all these you know disparate
tools is a major problem and we actually
can show that we are formally verifiable
in the sense that any synchronous
circuit you build they can actually show
an equivalent asynchronous circuit
functionally timing-wise behaviorally
accurate so that makes it it's a very
interesting inner feature and then what
we have done is basically in order to
leverage compute what we've done is we
just took arm m3 cortex m3 and a DSP
from NXP called NXP cool flux DSP and
put together an asynchronous core that
that basically interfaces in the real
world using just a regular you know you
are in the band
USB and so on interfaces but then have
the DSP ADC and the cortex m3 completely
asynchronous so we have this technology
to do that this is the chip that
actually is a it's a five square
centimeter
sorry 25 square centimeter chip so the
four panels you see here is a solar
cells there that just runs on the solar
cells you can basically you know for
this particular chip that we are looking
at for four examples you know we have
128 kilobytes of RAM 512 kilobytes of
flash that's it we can support up to 2
kilo
mm neurons and about 128 thousand
synapses it runs at about 60 megahertz
max speed consuming just 2 milli watts
and the other thing is we can actually
dial up and down the voltage so we can
sort of go from point 2 volts all the
way to 1.2 volts and by doing that we
can manage how much we want a trade-off
between speed and efficiency so for
example if you want to run it really
fast
I may require a higher voltage but if I
can keep it slow and low which is
typically what is spiking model
typically operates about maybe you know
hundreds of kilohertz even bigger a huge
bang for the buck and then the other
point is that we are currently focusing
as a small company we are we are about
25 engineers not too much funding yet
but we are focusing only on 55
nanometers to keep our cost low as well
so these chips are 55 nanometer chips
and this plot here I just wanted to show
you is we compare very favorably with
any of the synchronous chips that you'll
find out there so the x-axis is
basically the speed y-axis is the is the
power and what you want to be is you
want to consume you know you want to go
as fast as you can but consume as little
energy as you want you possibly can and
these are all commercially available
chips against which we have benchmarked
our chip so we run at about 2 milli
watts for 60-plus megahertz that's the
rate so 30 micro watts per megahertz if
you will that's the rate at which we go
and it's actually mildly quadratic let
this plot so if I have a problem
I can just run at hundreds of kilohertz
I'm talking about microwatts as opposed
to milli watts even so what we're trying
to do is we are trying to leverage so in
this asynchronous mode of operation we
are trying to leverage spiking dynamics
actually to run at low frequencies
deliberately because then we can exploit
this low-voltage operation so I can run
at 0.2 volts instead of 1.2 volts and as
we all know square of the voltage is
addicting the data correlate to the
power so the lower the voltage I can get
much better bang for the buck so to
speak in terms of efficiency so that's
what we're trying to do and we have the
cool thing about this is that the the m3
is basically software programmable a
high-level language I don't really need
a custom language or a particular you
know set of tools to to program this in
I can just use a traditional language
C++ for example and I can just excuse
this as a hypothesis testing machine I
can have all kinds of models parameters
and dynamics we have demonstrated
already some some applications that are
very interesting I'll show you two demos
to conclude my talk but then key words
part in continuous speech recognition in
the watch domain and then we also
starting to look at the image and health
monitoring applications so I will show
you the first example would be its
continuous speech recognition model so
what we did is Google has this data set
called the the Google speech command
data set which is compiled it has about
2300 speakers are Turing 30 words you
know and and so basically it's a it's a
bunch of data it's very useful for us to
sort of calibrate and see where we are
what we can do is we can take the data
and using a single pass through the data
meaning once I process the signal I'll
talk about that and I just have to run
one instance of each sample through the
system I can get up to 96 percent
accuracy and a 10-digit problem and then
85 percent accuracy the 30 word problem
this is very comparable to the to the
other solutions that are out there so I
just need five
hundred neurons 25,000 synapses each
synapse being eight plaits
what we do is I'll show you the demo but
basically there's a PC mic and we have
our own ADC that takes the digitized
voice to the chip and then the DSP
extracts spectrograms in the voice data
and then off we go in terms of the spike
the spectrogram which is in current form
of spikes then I'll figure trying to use
our async so record and model
asynchronous hardware and ideas of
balanced balanced resonance to do to
train the system the bottom line here is
that we just require four kilobytes of
programs for the program memory and the
DSP and snn comes in 32 kilobytes and we
can run this as 2 milli watts basically
so let me play this video so this is
basically the continuous speech
recognition problem so the main point
here is the Google data set the each
instance of the word was uttered for one
second just one were like 1 or 0 or
whatever that's one second and what
we're trying to do here is teach
together a bunch of these words and try
to recognize what they are so this is a
little more trickier than there's no
segmentation really and so we had a deal
with that so let me so this this this
hardware that you see here actually the
interface the signal comes in from the
from the PC mic through this board here
and all this extra bells and whistles
you really don't care about that's the
chip that we we actually run our stuff
on there's a DSP out here and that's
basically running the the filtering of
the pre-processing so we are off we're
trying to offer an end-to-end solution
not just saying oh it's somebody else's
problem - to bring the data to the right
format for the chip to learn we want to
do everything you want to take the data
and then draw data and then process the
whole thing that went a stack basically
so let me now run it
so we're just gonna
jack up the volume a little bit
that's a turd grab grab by the mic and
then the system just produces a response
right there
so in a crowded scenario doing the same
thing there
that's the answer there and then longer
sequences where things start getting
squished so on so that there's a whole
bunch of demos we have set up and we're
actually showing this to folks as we go
along here so - since yesterday we
talked about people talk about em nest
and it's a classic benchmark we
obviously through this the same idea
onto that to see what it does and so we
just need exactly the same Network 500
neurons with 25,000 synapses 8 bits per
synapse and here we instead of having
the spectrogram transfer into the chip
we have an image that is transferred
into the chip using a DSP to pre-process
the amnesty into the right format and we
encode them into spikes and here's the
confusion matrix for the for the 10,000
image images in the in the MLS test set
and the numbers look very similar to
what you saw before for kilobytes about
60 kilobytes of memory here because it's
an image and power is about 1 milli watt
so let me run this video
so you could just have a screen you just
cry whatever you want and it would tell
you what it thinks it is and it would go
on and on
remember this is not a scene in the test
set because you were just writing it
there's lots of variations in fact
you'll find that you know there's a lot
of things you can do to mess this up
so so basically essentially you know
just uh my point here was just drawing
inspiration from some features in
biology that we know about and being
able to architect a chip that allows us
to do this very efficiently seems to
suggest that there is a possibility at
least that we could put the push this to
the edge so to speak so the devices that
we carry the sensors and the nodes that
are showing up and billions of these
going to show up in the future but
there's a potential there for offer for
some of these technology to filter into
that space where we can exploit you know
what we learned from neurobiology and
neuroscience and and shows up in
electronics that actually does something
useful so with that I'll just summarize
my talk here so this you know brain
evolved to strike this balance between
information processing and energy
consumption these are the four pillars
are all around which our system is set
up sink spiking neural models
asynchronous computing analog signal
processing and hardware architecture
variations that are derived from what we
saw in biology or what we see in biology
asynchrony in computing seems to be a
very important requirement or for
getting that efficiency and in
furthermore our innovation allows us to
dial down the voltage and if you have
spiking models that makes it even better
because our operating rates are much
lower so that seems to be a key
principle spiking neural models with
plasticity and this analog signal
processing allows us to do this
end-to-end solution at the edge and we
believe that you know that's a very
important factor coming in because any
comparison you make has to cover the
end-to-end part of it otherwise if it's
somebody else's problem to solve part of
the pre-filtering or the or the retinal
problem versus the cortex problem that's
a whole nother ballgame as several
applications are being tested and it
seems to hold promise for for the edge
with that I will I will stop on time and
be happy to take questions thank you
[Applause]
yeah okay you tell us any more about the
neurons and the synapses yeah so it's
the basic integrate linking to get in
fire neurons the synapses are eight bits
and AB says it's software programmable
so right now it's just a you know the
ones that have a trace basically a
synaptic trace and you can model it
trace based on the the timing of the
pulses right so we haven't even touched
the part where the engineering of the
circuits to actually mimic that is not
so what I'm saying is even without that
just exploiting a synchrony at at the
level where it gets so right now it's
too early to sort of we all know that
you know we don't know the answers mean
all the answers right so rather than peg
ourselves into some particular model we
want the option of being flexible and
being able to program it in and she
seems like there are some principles
that work very nicely with this kind of
approach so if you notice in the EM mist
case so what we did was so we mimicked a
sock art so we just go left to right top
to bottom generate sequences of spikes
where the spike is basically changes in
information along each line so if I go
along the line if there's a transition
between dark and white there's a pulse
otherwise it keeps quiet and then again
the other way around so such a positive
negative specs for each row so I get a
sequence of those spikes the sequence of
these spikes and then we just rotate the
image once 45 and another 45 as if I'm
circling looking at the object this way
or that way and I generate the same
sequences and that's my input flow into
the system that's the input part of it
now the in terms of learning itself so
we have plasticity both and the in the
excitatory synapses as well as the
inhibitory synapses meaning that we want
to dynamically control the balance in
the currents rather than in
worried about an imbalance so the
plasticity and the synapses are for both
so they sort of keep the control also so
that the number of spikes that are
generated by the system is very low it's
very sparse and then furthermore the
decoding we use something like a
temperature on the variation of a
temperature on to classify so to speak
what do you so yeah I don't make a claim
that this is the answer I'm just saying
that you know you're right absolutely
there are many codes you're right
absolutely as we all know and we're
talking about latency code here so the
timing between the pulses is where the
signal is encoded and and and so what
I'm trying to say is if you have that
mode of operation where you have a
delicate balance in the currents then
you get a very sparse activity but you
can learn very well as well so you can
really learn well even with it sparse
activity and furthermore because of the
hardware running it at low frequencies
mean it gives me the option to dial down
the voltage I can just go down to point
to words you know and that gives me a
huge advantage so that's still in the
edge word right the edge world you have
very limited memory you have the size
weight area power constraints and now
they're throwing latency they're
throwing all these other requirements as
well so we are talking about much
smaller you know things that have to
work in a very small footprint with very
small area so it's a very different
concept of consciousness think of as
beetles are you know more like rather
than worrying about but we are going to
we're gonna write software programs to
sort of figure out maybe overtime maybe
working with other other folks to see
well is there a potential to scale up
this thing and what is that that's
something yeah
so the arm core is synchronous we know
that right
it's a narco you can bite off the shelf
but what we have done to it is we have
built some bridges that allows us to do
complete asynchrony in the processing
arm processor so you can write code in
the art for C code that runs
asynchronously on the arm core so that's
our innovation so basically we don't so
we don't they're not slaves to the
global clock anymore and this is for the
core as well as the DSP so all of a
sudden you know I get the retinal stuff
as well as the processing stuff
asynchronous okay
so that's the key and so once we do that
be finding that that in fact that
dominates everything else the choice of
the model you know things like that but
what works also matters something has to
work that has to do what what I just
showed you right that's what that's the
other problem of course modeling is
probably most of the problem but then in
terms of hardware what we find is that
seems to be a big principle that we have
two extra we sort of exploit in order to
do well keep the energy low which is
important for the edge you know so we
can run peak rates of 60 megahertz I
mentioned that we're at 60 megahertz we
consume two milliwatts okay so arm can
probably quadruple that right but then
they consume hundreds of hundreds of
millivolts so about 400 to 500 milli
watts sphere we refuse for factor of 100
patter you know comparatively speaking
and furthermore if you want to run you
know more complex problems we may end up
requiring a higher bandwidth but with
spikes it seems that you
can sort of play with that too so you
can sort of ah your signals can be your
visual signals are 30 Hertz to 60 Hertz
right that come into the camera let's
say doublet let's say quadruplet it
still doesn't matter in terms of
frequency your auditory signals are in
the kilohertz range so you know we're
talking 60 megahertz so there's a
there's a box to play in basically and
you're playing in that box you see what
can be leveraged at the edge so that's
the so we use yeah so maybe I can talk
to you offline because so there is a so
rather than doing a random graph so what
we do is we ensure that the there's some
orthogonal properties for the weight
vector that we use to initialize the the
graph and furthermore this plasticity in
the synapses allows us to keep the
current always balanced so it
continuously I've written this stuff in
palos computational biology 20 I can
send you the link to that anything else
thanks a lot
[Applause]